the initial balance breakout has a 97%
chance of happening. In this video, I'm
going to break down exactly how I've
been using that statistic to just print
money on futures. What is going on guys?
Mr. Zinc here. Jumping right into it,
the initial bounce breakout is the first
60 minutes of market open. As most of
you know, I like to trade on the
15-minute time frame. So, that is the
first four 15minute candles. The high or
low made in that time frame gives you
the initial balance.
What you do with this concept is you're
looking for the break of the high or
low. And this has a 97% chance of
happening. If we go over to Edgeful and
view the data, 74.6% of the time it is
only going to break one of those levels.
23.02%
of the time it's going to break two of
those levels, the high and the low. And
only 2.38% of the time it is not going
to break either. Looking at this chart,
looking at the concept here, the high is
made from the wick high, the low is made
from the wick low. The first 60 minutes,
it has a 3% chance of staying inside
that range. So, if that happens, if the
high is, let's say, 570 and the low is
565, you have a 3% chance that price
will consolidate within that $5 range
for the rest of the trading day. If that
happens, close the charts. Sayanara, no
need to trade during that chop. Now, the
concept itself is taking advantage of
that 97% statistic. I don't care if it's
a single break or a double break because
that is a trading strategy on its own.
What I care about is the possibility of
a no break.
Inversing that 2.38% that means that
it's a 97.62%
chance of having a break of one of those
levels. In this case, we're looking for
a break of the high. Our entry is, let's
say, 20 to 30 points away from the high.
We put a reasonable stop loss in. We
move the stop loss up as it gets closer
to our takerit.
If it hits break even, so be it. But
we're taking advantage of the
possibility that it's a 97% chance of
breaking that high or low. Once that
higher low is broken, it's only a 25 uh
24% chance to go and break the opposing
side. In this case, we're looking for a
break of the high. There's only a 24%
chance to break the low. On the other
side of that, once the high is broken,
it's only a 32% chance to continue to
0.5 standard deviation. We're going to
cover exactly what that means coming up
shortly.
Essentially, what this means is once
that high or low of the initial balance
is broken, there's not really much to do
for trading afterwards.
Given today's price action, this is our
initial bounce. We have the 9:30 open
and the close of that 10:15 candle
10:30. That's our initial bounce that we
were given today. In this case, probably
going to gravitate towards the high. So,
what I did, and we're in replay mode
right now. What I did today is I ended
up taking longs about 20 points away
from that high and it shot right through
it. Now, this is an indicator on
Trademue that Edgeful has. If you go and
buy Edgeful or get the monthly
membership, you get access to all their
indicators. One of them being the
initial balance breakout indicator. It
gives you the high and low charted
automatically for every day of the week
as soon as it happens real time. Now,
going to this last slide, there's only a
32% chance that price continues to that
0.5 standard deviation. What the
standard deviations are is the size of
the initial balance. So if the initial
balance is $2.50 like it is today, that
means that one standard deviation away
from that is $2.50 above 57040
and so on. Half the standard deviation
125. Edgeful also has an indicator for
that. And there's the level that we
rejected off today. We happened to hit
that 32% chance and then we ended up
reversing and hitting both the 32%
chance of hitting 0.5 standard deviation
and also going all the way down and
hitting a double break which is only a
24% chance or in this case 23% chance
back tested for the past three month uh
six months excuse me that's the concept
itself based on these slides as soon as
we have that level broken and it's with
a wick that could be 1 cent. It could be
a wick that's a dollar. As soon as the
high or low of the initial balance is
broken, the concept is washed. You're
not taking any trades after that. You're
not trying to target the initial balance
low. You're not trying to retest a a
bounce off of that initial balance high.
Once you hit the initial break, the
initial bounce breakout, that's the 97%
statistic. Once that happens, you're no
longer looking to go long. you're no
longer looking to go short. You're only
anticipating the break itself. Now, what
happened yesterday, and this one was
pretty funny. I took longs at about
1032,
uh maybe a little bit after, maybe a
little bit before. Looking for that
initial bounce high. I had a stop loss
at $1,000. Moved it up to break even. It
got hit at break even. I re-entered.
I'll go I'll go down to the five minute
for this.
I re-entered on another dip which
happened at 10:30. Stop loss at a
negative,000. The candle wicked all the
way back up. I was up about 1,200. Move
the stop loss to $400 in the profit and
then it wicked me out again. You are not
blindly taking or I'm not blindly taking
longs when it's within the middle of
that range because it could go either
way. Just because it's 97% that it's
going to break one of the levels, there
are a couple days that happen to not
break the level. I'm increasing my odds
of having a high or low break by waiting
for it to gravitate towards that
naturally. Now, on the opposing side of
that, we also go and chart our London
50, and that helps with the entries. Our
London 50 model we put in at the 4 am
high. London low happened to be at 850.
We dragged that out to the right. Look
where price rejected trying to get back
to that initial balance breakout high.
Once we got to the low, I took short at
because we broke below London low.
My take profit was at that initial
balance low and we missed it by a
whopping three cents.
three whole cents. So, this has yet to
break. The initial balance was still
intact going into close. And I took
longs right before close. Uh I believe I
took them at 230. Rode them up. Uh
managed to get them all the way up to
56471. I was up $800 in this position.
Trailed my stop loss to $400 in the
profit. Got wicked out and then it
proceeded and broke the initial balance
high. This can happen. It's a macro data
point. It doesn't mean it's going to
happen immediately.
You're looking for entries along the
way. You're looking for other points of
confluence, whether it be the London 50
model, whether it be fair value gaps,
change in state delivery, whatever your
concept is that you're trading alongside
the initial balance breakout. That helps
with your entries. This isn't something
you just blindly take longs or shorts
waiting for it to break out. You're
making calculated risk. In this case,
what I like to do, give it 20 to 30
points away from the high or low. Put a
stop loss at negative a thousand, add
2NQ, 3NQ. If it goes and hits the high
or low, great. If my stop loss hits, I
wait for it to get in another setup,
wait for it to go target the long, the
high, whatever it might be. Now, there
are other statistics on Edgeful. You can
go and look at reports as in uh what is
the buy rejection and this one measures
if the initial balance low is formed
first. This is your percent chance of
going and hitting the high. Going back
to today's price action,
uh Wednesday, September 3rd.
There we go. Get rid of that one. We
formed the low first. And you can see
that we formed the low at 9:45 and then
the high was formed at 10:25.
The very next candle, the 10:30 candle,
ended up breaking it. So, this was maybe
two minutes that I was in the trade for
the initial balance high. But this gives
you another set of confluence if you're
looking to go long or short. This is
saying because the low was formed first,
one out of five times the low will get
broken first. Whereas, four out of five
times, four out of five trading days of
the week, the high will get broken
first. We were close to the high. We are
within 30 points. Two points of
confluence for me to go long. Long long.
I believe I was 25 MNQ. So 2 and a half
NQ and then 2NQ. Two trades. Ended up
closing the day at $1,500. Yes, these
are combines for now, but we are testing
the concept.
Now that I'm going to pass these
combines after this $1,500 day, we're
going to deploy the strategy with the
same sizing that we did on the combines,
same stop-loss, same concept, using the
data backed by Edgeful. That's a quick
breakdown of how I've been using the
initial balance breakout. Again, for
today's example, once we broke that
initial balance, I'm no longer looking
to trade today. So, I don't care if it
was a double break. I don't care if it
was a single break. I don't care if
price reverses all the way back up,
breaks it for a third time. My trade was
at 10:30 once the initial high was
broken.
No more trades after that. Make our
money, get out of the market, go do some
projects, whatever I want to do for the
rest of the day. Hope you enjoyed this
video. If you want some more of these,
drop a comment. Make sure you like and
subscribe. I'll post another video on
just a recap of this concept later this
week. See you guys later.